you Dallas remember the Canadian shop
teacher who decided to pull the kids in
his class into his weird sexual fetishes
the teacher goes by the name of Kayla
Lemieux
showed up in enormous fake prosthetic
breasts and wagged them at the kids and
for months the Cowardly School Board in
Ontario that would be the Halton
District School Board defended this
creep but now Under Pressure including
the threat of legal action from parents
they appear to be backing down a little
bit the school board says it will
require a professional dress code from
teachers meaning smaller prosthetic
breasts apparently
well the Canadian media ignored this
story Rebel news did not it's reporter
David Menzies has been on it from the
very beginning he joins us tonight David
thanks so much uh for coming on you look
great by the way
um well you know you know Tucker on
network TV as they say
as they say give them the jiggle with
the giggle right
that is 100 and look as long as you feel
empowered we're for it
um tell us like how since you are
wearing the costume of the shop teacher
in Ontario
I mean I mean how
Could you teach shop class wearing those
things I guess just to just a court
competency first
oh uh Tucker you could not in fact I've
always said forget about the Ministry of
Education where's the Ministry of Labor
uh long sleeves long hair not done up in
a bun or a hair net jewelry
um Bussy Lemieux breaks every shop
etiquette rule in the book and by the
way just in case
um your audience thinks um I've attached
myself to some kind of fetish lifestyle
or I'm a drag queen Storyteller For Hire
uh no that's not the case uh we I went
there to the Halton District School
Board back in October dressed exactly
like uh busty Lemieux the the sheer
blouse with the nipples protruding the
blonde hair the bicycle shorts and
here's the thing about the hypocrisy of
the Halton District School Board Tucker
they're all down with the radical
transgender uh agenda but only when it's
in front of the kids when it's in front
of their school board meeting they
actually fled the room and I have
subsequently being banned for life for
Life Tucker from Halton District School
Board headquarters and all their schools
uh because I guess um I was asking
impolite questions and they don't like
the idea of drag when it comes to them
now the news Tucker is that earlier this
month the hdsb trustees approved the
request to the education director his
name is Curtis Innis he him and what
they want to do is uh craft a
professionalism policy to maintain
appropriate and Professional Standards
of dress in the classroom now maybe you
and your viewers are saying wait a
minute isn't this deja vu all over again
didn't they
um look into this back in November and
yes they did and it was rejected in
November
um by Sarah
saritaha who was uh who is their Human
Resources superintendent so two things
here um Tucker what would change from
November until March I don't think
anything has and also that Director of
Education uh critician is he him he
released a statement where he
essentially said that um he might veto a
dress code recommendation that they will
continue to be you know
um answerable to Human Rights Equity etc
etc so the hdsb is kind of like
professional wrestling nothing is real
until it happens
I don't know what's going on up there
we're gonna have to visit your country
sometime soon is to check it out and I
have to say I'm a little bit sympathetic
to the school board because I am
intimidated by your prosthetic breasts
and may need to flee um but I appreciate
it coming on anyway David Menzies thank
you of Rebel news
my pleasure Tucker thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else